We have a voicemail number. That number is
two one nine two. David P. I love it when
I get voicemails like this. Many of you know,
English is my second language.
Uh, I uh, initially spoke Spanish for the
first roughly six years of my life. I came
to the U S knowing two words stop and blue.
And I remember seeing a stop sign when we
arrived and left the airport in 1989 and,
uh, because I immediately recognized a word,
I thought this is going to be great. I'm going
to do great at this. So anyway, uh, I got
a a voicemail from someone who considers themselves
sort of a linguist. And who is saying, David,
I know English is your second language. You
use the word that doesn't exist yesterday
except the word does exist. Take a listen
to this voicemail.
Hey Dave, this is doc Smith calling. Um, look,
it's a little bit, a bit of a linguist. I
just wanted to tip you off. You kind of, uh,
use the word that didn't exist about nine
minutes, nine minutes or so. And your show
on the seventh, you talked about, uh, the
framers you were talking about checks and
balances out of the framers never anticipated
having somebody like president Trump who would
fill out wrong word. The word is wants F,
L a, U N T either in that flaunt the norms.
Now to your credit, English is your second
language. I understand that. And I can also
say I've heard several other media folks also
use that.
Listen, um, if you are a linguist, I would
imagine you would Google the word. The word
is flout, F L. O. U. T. and it sounds like
you are a native English speaker, but I understand
that we do have problems in the United States
with, with education. The word is flout. The
definition is to openly disregard, to disregard
a rule or a law, a convention or a norm. I
spoke correctly. Donald Trump is flouting
the checks and balances and norms and laws
that were put in place by the framers of the
United States in that he is disregarding them.
It's not flaunting. Flaunting would actually
be the wrong word here. Flout is the correct
word. The more you know, we have a great bonus
show for you today. We will talk about that
Covington high school lawsuit. We will talk
about alcohol related deaths up drastically
in the United States, and a very interesting
being, a universal basic income trial being
funded by a Japanese billionaire. All of those
stories and more on the bonus show, get access
instantly at join Pacman duck, the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].